- So, have you ever seen anything happen,
like through your window,
like watching your neighbors?
- No, I'm not, I'm gonna
spare you the details.
I don't watch my neighbors,
but I am like secretly nosy.
Like I'm all over the Nextdoor app.
I've got to know what's happening and-
- What's that?
(audience laughing)
- It is the most
dramatic, slash wonderful,
slash way to find lost
dogs, app on the Internet.
It's called Nextdoor.
You sign up, your whole
community gets to be like
does anyone want these colored pencils?
I don't need them anymore.
Has anyone seen my dogs?
The other day, is this your iguana?
There was an iguana on a car.
- [Kelly] It's like a
new way to be a neighbor.
- [Kristen] Yeah, it's like nosy neighbors
but you don't need to
look out your window.
So I'm all over Nextdoor.
- Okay.
Now your neighbors are
all like- (laughing)
- They're ll over it too.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- We keep tabs on each
other. We keep tabs on each.
- [Kelly] I love that,
I never heard of that.
- [Kelly] Oh, it's incredible.
- It's super helpful.
- [Kristen] I beg you to sign up.
- Okay okay. I'm not really an
app girl, don't tell anyone.
So, but well, here's what
your neighbors see though,
when they look at your house.
We saw this.
So this is-
- [Kristen] Yeah.
- [Kelly] This is you.
- This is you.
- Yeah.
- First of all, Dax, congratulations.
Congratulations. I just need to say it.
Like way to go, buddy.
- In my defense, that's
the back of the house.
And I don't think anyone can really see
unless they have like a
telescope or something.
- [Kelly] If I looked like
that, who cares if they see?
Take the shot.
- Look, I grew up in the theater.
- I'm gonna do it in my front
yard if I look like you.
- But like, I'm not going outside like in,
I'm not taking in the trash like that.
But if I'm like waking up on a Saturday
and I wanna go get coffee
or matcha from the kitchen,
like, and if I had slept
nude, then I'm going in nude.
The problem is, he always busts me
because I wear really high socks.
But I don't take those off.
- [Kelly] Cause your
socks, your feet get cold.
- Yeah, my feet get cold.
- Me too, yeah.
- [Kristen] And so I
keep them on compression.
It's really nice.
So he's always like
snapping pictures of me
where I'm like this,
but then just like amazing
thick grandpa socks.
- [Kelly] Oh my God, I love it.